[Musique]
vous n'êtes que vous avez
personnellement adressé à monsieur
bernard arnault vous volez au secours de
son conseil d'administration
sans aucun fondement juridique sans
aucun argument solide et en créant un
précédent historique en matière de
diplomatie française la protection
d'intérêts privés et de liens
privilégiés
auraient-elles dépasser la défense de
l'intérêt général
dans une démocratie nous devons
combattre toutes les tentations
d'instrumentalisation de l'état il en va
de la crédibilité du politique de la
crédibilité de crédibilité de la france
et donc de notre souveraineté en février
dernier avec mon collègue olivier marc
l'ex nous avions déjà interpellé le
ministre de l'économie sur la crise de
gouvernance chez angie dénonçant un
probable plan caché du gouvernement
malheureusement nous avions vu juste
avec l'offensive hostile de veolia pour
démanteler suez
nous dénonçons au contraire votre
légèreté coupable sur les dossiers
industriels en acceptant la casse
sociale d'un fleuron français avec une
prévision de 10 mille emplois supprimés
et ce au moment même où notre pays
traverse une crise économique sans
précédent
la semaine dernière le groupe japonais
bridgestone a annoncé la fermeture de
son usine de pneus de béthune dans les
hauts de france 8 163 salariés en cdi
sont menacés par cette annonce ainsi
qu'une centaine de sous-traitants
c'est un carnage sociale cette caste
sociale n'est que l'énième exemple de la
désindustrialisation de notre pays face
à cela nous ne pouvons pas accepter des
méthodes qui met en péril la vie de
milliers de salariés
on ne peut pas vouloir la
réindustrialisation de notre pays et le
maintien des emplois sans faire
comprendre à ces groupes qui si en
france le diptyque on prend l'argent et
on cyr ne marche pas
mais pourquoi attribuer si facilement
les fréquences 5 g sans contrepartie
pourquoi vous priver de moyens de
pression sur les opérateurs une pression
salutaire pour qu'ils déterminent enfin
le déploiement de la 4g dans notre pays
l'égalité des chances ou numérique pour
tous les français où qu'ils habitent ou
qu'ils travaillent pour cette france des
territoires qui a bien compris que la
société du tout numérique aggrave les
inégalités dans ce plan de relance je
m'étonne de l'absence de certains
secteurs stratégiques comme celui de la
défense
cette filière industrielle d'excellence
regroupant 4000 entreprises travaillant
à la fois pour la défense et pour le
civil soit deux cent mille salariés
monsieur le premier ministre devant ces
réalités comment se fait-il que le
secteur industriel de la défense sur le
grand oublié de ce plan de relance 6 la
semaine dernière s'est tenue la séance
plénière du parlement européen seule
institution de l'union européenne
implantée en france
or celle ci était organisée à bruxelles
et ce pour la sixième fois consécutive
depuis le début de l'année en totale
contradiction avec les traités européens
il en va monsieur le premier ministre du
poids politique et diplomatique de la
france
il en va du leadership france est avec
l'allemagne en europe
il en va de la place de la france sur la
scène internationale
si la problématique du logement persiste
dans l'hexagone elle est d'autant plus
importante dans nos territoires
ultramarins il nous faut relever des
défis supplémentaires depuis la crise qu
vide
[Musique]